deine fragen
ritter
[Musik]
es ist wie überall alter buch seiner
wahl ein anderes als der ganz große
druck stress hektik
trotzdem dran glauben
[Musik]
das kann man das auge ist weg die mauer
mona vetsch drehtag bin dj bobo gut
vorbereitet auf alles gefasst
das ist mona mit drin
das ist die mona und ist aber zu gucken
sondern der welt
dann lasse ich jetzt
[Musik]
ja
zu jeder plusminus weißwasser tour hatte
nicht wie neue mädchen- und cagliari
ich meine wie um gottes willen wird man
für techniker was ist in meiner jugend
ja ja ja das ist absolut verständlich
und blitzen in elten kleine explosion
und wurde immer mehr und dann doch nicht
realisiert als pyromanie die show
bekannt und mit dem rené baumann alias
dittsche botschafter sie 20 hasen alles
hochexplosive war nebeneffekt probieren
sich die heiden thüringer wald
als büro lehrling nicht ganz ohne andre
helf mit komplexeren aufgaben krämpfe
[Musik]
zum beispiel mit der hebebühne
er wird so steil dass alle daten werden
[Musik]
sie fühlt sich noch immer vom gurt lösen
jenen druck so bescheuert ist es
offiziell der januar als shylock
[Musik]
sie wirken aber dass der druck immens
irgendwie haben haben es gibt immer
paaren fk nix dran programme
internetshop macht nicht genannt ich
glaube partizipation vielseitig
wird doch besser mit der erfahrung so
die erde entstand aber doch eins wird
besser du hast die gewissheit dass es am
schluss alles gut kommt so stehen
ja da wurde das typische perfektionisten
die sich natürlich steht die wusste dass
mir das ist gerade der begrüßung seither
sind dazu zählen das noch nicht
funktioniere
geniales video läden land muss man auch
erzeugen wie die zeitversetzt
wenn ich also wüste büro
[Gelächter]
den sieg machten ort sich trainer
baumann noch gerne karten
[Musik]
ich danke drei gewerke gebiet
großstädter sind
[Musik]
die vier musiker zu hören wie ihr
automatisch dazu
[Musik]
chefdesigner bonitaire ist sondern ein
sie einbußen frau sie ist auch sängerin
im score mit verschiedenen hitparaden
stürmen auf die bühne standen und ich
habe großes vor hat mir gesagt wenn sie
wir sehen uns nie das geht so nicht und
da habe ich gesagt wir probieren aus ich
mache eine tour aber wenn es nicht geht
bin ich habe einfach zum gesagt du musst
mir meinen platz lassen und ich lass dir
das alles nur eine frage das heißt nicht
dass ich meine sachen arbeiten will ohne
dass er maximal was ich sage mir auch
nicht was er komponieren soll oder damit
ist das nancy sales director zu erzeugen
was du arbeite das nicht aus
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
nancy und apropos sie dachte und 2 sind
und überhaupt die frage wer ihm
praktisch jeder verbindet alami schicht
mit dem buch auf ihn zu
[Gelächter]
zum glück kann ich dem anderen über lord
ist für knalleffekte
der welt-premiere wo sich mit der kanone
hand tiere das ist das teil
[Musik]
das wird mein job seien dann am
höhepunkt der dj bobo premiere werde ich
dann im publikum das gilt für diese
sollen die wohnungslos
[Gelächter]
es sieht nur noch essbar minute bis zum
startschuss vor der generalprobe
ein potenter von der ersten stunde statt
asia zum ersten mal
der erfinder von choreografie zum ersten
mal regie erhebt das ganze programm
zimmer mit pyromanie oft 40 uhr die
große flammenwerfer lord umjubelte
weltpremiere für das buch c lizenz von
häusern entlang auf dem lagerfeuer
richtig holz temperaturen ist da muss
darauf 8 bis dadurch gerade ein kind
schläft oder kanone drückst du stehst
vor ist die mobile freshness
[Musik]
[Applaus]
krenz mikrofon griff
euro technisch leipzig wie süd
[Applaus]
hebebühne blieb das problem
[Musik]
bitte nennen sie ihn rechts praktisch
nichts
[Musik]
und auch die kostüme postmoderne dann
ist er es liebt - mit
wieder im soll müsste eigentlich vier
freien robert zum dj bobo flüge aber
nummer 1 hit wie klar
[Musik]
nur der mann hat alles im griff
[Applaus]
warum
als ich stimmung war toll und wir haben
noch viel zu arbeiten
die politik aus
der hohle duisburg nach der show und
alle direkt so lage besprechen also
allium satiren kamera
franken
in zwei jahren
wenn kritisiert wird ist marvin bot ihm
lieber unter sich
besprochen wird bis tief in die nacht
ganz japan auf sieg eingestellt wurden
jeder einzelne
[Musik]
besonders unter druck
jungs von flügen der roboter bauprofis
für sie alles andere als optimal
gelaufen
[Musik]
so kreierten die teil des produktes
umgestellt müssen die eltern
funktioniert sondern auch die krankheit
da war es nötig haben extrem
magnetfelder da legte einen starken
gegner aus ist es dass wir uns wachsen
wird zu beurteilen wie sie und den drei
davon gegen oder und hier auf
natürlichem weg zurück ist
was bedeutet aber macht es dann und
darum sind auch im kampf verloren
monika ließ ihm vier trägern schafe ich
bin zwar smeets drin aber gleich
irgendwie in plauderlaune ist definitiv
niemand
sind die 10 grad
morgens ins kostüm fertig zu machen
[Musik]
das macht
mehr gesehen
die beine sagte bochums wegen welche
posten welche bürgern erlaubt ihr sprach
kurz kommen weil wir haben also hier das
sagen wir mal ob dies auf das
funktionieren kann mit dem was macht man
wenn sie auf alle fälle aber alles daran
spielt heißt bei kostümen aber muss man
jetzt da müssen wir erst mal eine lösung
finden wir ja schon technische chemische
eine neue welt das heißt
in ihre eigene welt so viele sind am
rhein new tomorrow und orange ist er der
ruhende pol
diese glauben war das extra versenkt
damit man das dann folgen sind die leute
sehen davon wolle nun mal groß
am krater sind für werk rechte drin und
die immer noch zeigt dir irgendwie rené
zuerst alles was er vorhat und dann
sagst du warst du dir da vorstellen
kannst aber wie funktioniert das war mir
damals zusammen es gibt eine vorstellung
die bühne wird er geplant sondern ist
ein sprechender platz und auch überlegen
und was könnte da passen was für einen
posten der musik und zeige ich ihnen die
effekt ist also gibt ja aber das ist
eigentlich was er so in diesem ganzen
orchester von bobo bist du eigentlich
heißen investiert die kartenspieler ist
eine fassenden braucht aber richtigen
moment ist auch das entscheidende
richtigen moment ja augen spielen
[Musik]
der coach ist es nicht ein zusammen
danke ich möchte dass ihr profil auf der
bühne perfekt die robotik saison
persönlichkeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der abschied nicht leicht
[Musik]
der boa new team phoenix ich passe mich
mama resi 3
nichts
sechs wenigsten marie natürlich nett
aber das ist auch schon einmal selbst
schon mal vor publikum ausprobiert den
tropischen muss feedback und das spürt
man sofort wo man emotionale bogen
unterwegs ist das muss jetzt noch das
muss stimmen das für mich das wichtigste
frau ich sehen uns durch seine show oder
installiert waren der schon weiß ich
auch was sie den worten und mit dem kopf
so wenn ihr das kondom setzte nach einer
das hat unglaublich viel los du wirst
das zentrum dem motto wenn du musst in
dem sport zu nennen wo die anderen sind
ja jetzt wird er trug das kleid
der motor läuft turbo laufe der nacht
weg
so eine produktionsstätte der grenze für
alle
[Musik]
katar klingt einfach sein sich in die
familie sich so eine tolle und
übermorgen sie an ihr gerieben haben
dafür setzen und dann ist ja schon
wieder am brett
aber immer noch wachse verschuldung für
stück langsam ist und mehr scheuen will
den luftgeist probiere es einfach dass
vitali 48 schwierig der regisseur curtis
gibt sich überzeugt ich finde es genial
wenn sie es schaffen eine fliegen zu
lassen
beständig das mögen des ortes ich brauch
dass das wäre doch schon und wir haben
jetzt alles gemacht und unsere seite die
startplätze sind fordern dass ich bewege
mich nur von der dj bobo rät überall mit
vor den flügen der roboter bis zum
ticket worauf er weiß genau
doch nicht die frage ob er das schaffen
das auf zu machen das ist eigentlich wie
das ist voll ist aha als der punkt dass
wir wollen ihn verkaufen
im moment wird mit dem tv wo vom manager
vom chef smartphones schlagwörter weiß
ich nicht da bin ich nur noch künstler
wollen bin ich auch interessiert dann
auch in sachen ist ein lebensende alles
alles geglaubt mich interessiert auch
alles war schön überbleibt mich
interessiert ist auch warum ist die
kamera nicht gut warum ist das bild
nicht so wie ich denk und so weiter oder
umgekehrt bestehe also solange jedoch
neue sache machen
du wirst mich näher im festzelt sie
irgendwie hat er fast nach dem mini alte
hits spielen das höher steinegger das
kann ich würde ganz einfach weil ganz
diskret für mich wird die scheibe
minister dafür also rein finanziell ist
der job mache ich haben uns gerade mit
cds verkauft wo cdu weist der zehn
jahren richtig kohle gemacht einfach mit
musik weiß ich genau das ist früher und
damit eben ganz dunkel ist und auch nach
unserer guten schnitt so schlecht 715
millionen haben ok
[Musik]
seine produktion rund 1 million franken
dass er überlebte ich kam zur vbg
merklich der rhöner baumann ist nicht
nur ein künstlerisch vor allem und
geschäftsmann hätte firma aufbaut wo
sich um alles kümmert vom verlags reicht
bis zu den dicken jeder entscheid laufen
bringen
das zeigt sich wenige stunden vor der
premiere
[Musik]
die schweizer franken achtung kommen
bestimmt 20 prozent wir haben wir das
gemacht
hoffentlich weiß der andere welt und was
hast du gemacht wenn eine nicht
herumgeredet 11 sich das aber freundlich
für den schweizer ok dann zeit kulant
und 12 franken das ist ja nicht mehr so
weit auseinander dass die 112 gleich die
ganz große fans sind kopien soundcheck
mit wie sie in der extra teurere tickets
kauft zu nico buchen in alba
[Musik]
ich bin so aufgeregt
[Gelächter]
warum kommen die jetzt schreiben wir
dürfen welchen jeden preis geben
franken was was gefällt euch am ball
die show wird werde ich mit nimmt ja
denn es stimmt ja immer bildung hat
seinen dicken sondern der gt r power
gibt es tanz mit uns feiern und genießt
als geil
[Musik]
während fans schon jetzt im siebenten
himmel sind gottérons zwei stück vieh
truppe gut tun
trotzdem sind noch nicht bereit
ich muss eh zu man jetzt denkt ratlos
und ich wollte dass meine chance das ist
für die hier unterrichtet das brot sind
feiern dann ist das
b
ja noch nicht
wer ganz schlecht schließlich ein dj
bobo und system zwar auf dem moment
geschafft
[Musik]
und jetzt ist weltpremiere
meister
[Musik]
teresa es geschafft bist du mal
sogar und bobo sind länder schlug sich
rechtfertigen
[Applaus]
jetzt kommt mini satz langsam herum
einfach auf den roten knopf drücken muss
aber genau im richtigen moment
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit plan das ist nicht nur kräftig
druckgrafik denn wenn die pyromanie
abbucht
[Musik]
achtung
praktisch täglich oder wenigstens neun
toleranzbereich
und denkt der größte moment wir viel vor
der vier roboter messflüge
[Musik]
das unermüdliche tüftler hat sich
gelohnt
[Musik]
jetzt nur noch komplett die kanone zum
final im griff und da lass ich gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dankeschön
nach einer riesenchance
dann geht's gut jetzt wunderbar ich habe
zwar ein paar teile liegen lassen
und was meint dass eine klärung
für mich endet dort reis mit dem buch
für alle anderen gott sie erst richtig
los jetzt kommt die ganze truppe zweimal
auftun
[Musik]